researcher Murray selected two pairs of  Christmas stockings for testing all  decorated with the face of Santa Claus  the first pair was placed on the setting  course the output produced was a pair of  off-color red stockings with poorly  woven cotton the face of Santa was  replaced with a crude drawing of a stick  figure with a Christmas hat riding a  surfboard the phrase Aussie Christmas is  here was woven into the back with black  cotton the second pair was placed on the  setting fine the result was a cotton  vinyl containing the entire music  collection from the band bucko and  Champs with songs containing themes of  Christmas underlined with red lines  woven into the fabric